hey how's the sick year
I'm just signed up for filming an
episode today I brought you a present
Ayana and I already wrote the episode of
top five you don't even have to worry
about it here I'll read it for you
all right sounds good I'll try to stay
awake Ayana was one of the fair maidens
of top five she fell in love with a man
again and only true love would be able
to bring the two of them together for
them what is this is this a kissing
episode since movies first began love
has been a central theme whether it
drives the plot or is the butt of a joke
romance can be pivotal to any story
nothing quite illustrative better than a
kiss exchanged between two people
throughout the decades audiences have
experienced many passionate kisses but
which of these smooches is the best
these are the top five best movie kisses
number 5
more like broke news mountain ma lamech
sling ranch hands Ennis and Jack are
hired together to herd sheep for a
summer in the mountains while spending
long hours together in Wyoming
the two men become intimate they return
to their lives after the job is over but
Jack is not welcome back to work the
following summer after the man hiring
had observed his relationship with Ennis
Jack wants to start a life with Ennis
who refuses to leave his new family and
can't shake the memory of two men that
were attacked for accusations of a
homosexuality when he was young although
they cared for each other the 1960s were
not a time that same-sex relationships
were widely accepted Jack and Ennis
continued to reconnect on regular
fishing trips but both tried to move on
the memorable line I wish I knew how to
quit you is uttered during the moment
when Jack admits to Ennis that he's not
satisfied with their rendezvous is being
so infrequent there's a gap when the two
don't meet and settle into their
respective family lives when Jack visits
Ennis after four years the men share an
impassioned reunion kiss after all that
time apart It was as if nothing changed
between them while shooting director
Angley asked the actors to do the most
heroic Western kiss and Heath Ledger
almost broke Jake Gyllenhaal's nose
during the ensuing kiss their fleeting
moments together are full of anger and
passion since the only time they are
free to be their true selves is out in
the wilderness all of their intimacy
feels like they're constantly making up
for lost time
number 4
Titanic the film is a romantic take on
the historic disaster Kate Winslet plays
Rose a young passenger on the Titanic
who is in an undesirable engagement to
appease her family Rose feels trapped in
her life and decides to take control by
throwing herself from the ship
thankfully a stranger is there to stop
her from following through this handsome
stranger is Jack played by Leonardo
DiCaprio Rose gets to know Jack and
realizes that although they're from
separate social classes she's far more
attracted to him than her fiance Rose
attends parties with the lower class and
poses for Jack to sketch her and soon
their unlikely friendship quickly
evolves into much more when they first
recognize the romantic feelings for each
other there's a sense of excitement and
danger having a snake around after the
fateful iceberg collides with the ship
the danger becomes quite literal and
rose and Jack's feelings for each other
elevate in urgency there's a lot of
intimate moments throughout the film
that really moved the story forward but
none are as recognizable as the moment
they share on the bow of the Titanic
once in a desperate vulnerable place in
her life the stern of the ship was death
for her but in this moment at the
opposite end she's reminded of her
decision to live with the wind blowing
in her hair and putting her trust in
Jack's hands once more she opens her
eyes to the incredible sensation of
flying in the end their fleeting romance
was not meant to be as few survivors
made it out alive from the wreck
thankfully the a historical part of the
tale had a satisfying ending for the
lovers as Rose passes away in her old
age she's reunited with jack and the
others who lost their lives back on the
Titanic number three
[Music]
Oh
oh no not like that one this kiss
actually takes place early in the film
Sam played by Patrick Swayze walks in on
his girlfriend Molly played by Demi
Moore making pottery in the middle of
the night he playfully wrecks our
creation and joins her in the
not-so-subtle sensory activity the
Clay's messy and tactile giving the
couple other ideas this scene is so well
recognized that it's been spooked ad
nauseam and the Tsung Unchained memory
will forever be linked to pottery-making
later Sam and Molly are out for a walk
while disagreeing about saying I love
you all of a sudden the couple is mugged
and a shot rings out Sam doesn't realize
that he's died until he turns and he
sees his body in Molly's arms he can't
touch anything but he can see and hear
everything going on understandably molly
has trouble accepting his death and
feels his presence constantly Sam gets
in contact with old Mae a psychic played
by Whoopi Goldberg Sam asks her to relay
to Molly I love you but Molly knows that
he never says that at Sam's insistence
old me retorts with ditto
instead Molly has no choice but to
believe Sam doesn't know why he's still
around but old Mae knows he has
unfinished business so Sam learns to
interact with the physical world and
uses it to haunt his murderer and scare
him away from killing Molly too
eventually
molly is frustrated and still suspects
old Mae as a fraud but with Sam's new
abilities he proves that he's really
there and she's telling you truth as
much as he appreciates having a
spiritual conduit to talk with Molly
Sam still wishes he could touch her old
may suggest Sam use her physical form to
be with Molly one last time Unchained
Melody plays again as they reunite Molly
slow dance with old Mae mirrors the
earlier intimacy that Sam and Molly
shared but took for granted while he was
still alive making that kiss all the
more important
it's an incredibly original and touching
moment of love that transcends death
number 2
still over
we've seen a kiss done in the rain many
times in cinema but this rain kiss
struck a chord with audiences and
critics The Notebook follows the love
story of Noah and Allie they first meet
as teenagers when Allie is visiting
Noah's town for the summer it was love
at first sight
Noah pursued Allie persistently even
climbing a ferris wheel and threatening
to let go if Ali didn't agree to go on a
date with him
despite being from two different worlds
as Allie is a rich city girl and Noah's
from a working-class family they fall
deeply and truly in love by the end of
the summer they believe that they are
going to be together forever
Ali's family however tears them apart
and they break up seven years later
Noah is lonely and Allie is engaged she
sees Noah's picture in the paper after
he has completed a house that they
talked about restoring and living in
together and is compelled to go see him
no one takes Allie out in a boat to see
the Ducks as they are coming back to
shore they are caught in a rainstorm Ali
finally addresses the elephant in the
room and asks why Noah never wrote to
her they realized that their love never
faded and they never got over each other
the moment then builds to this
passionate kiss you can see the desire
pain and love in that instant it feels
almost desperate like they need to be
together in this moment no matter what
the rain adds to the romantic effect as
well the chemistry between rachel
mcadams and ryan gosling was electric
they even ended up dating in real life
it was a passionate and iconic kiss that
people still love fifteen years later
[Music]
and the number one fat movie Kip is
whether you think Peter Parker belongs
with Mary Jane or Gwen Stacy it's
impossible to forget this iconic kiss
Sam Raimi spider-man premiered in 2002
in case you haven't heard the basic
flatline in this or any of the many
Spyder and movies released since then
high schooler Peter Parker is bit by a
genetically modified super spider this
causes him to gain powers and become
your friendly neighborhood spider-man
from the beginning of the movie the
audience can see that Mary Jane is going
to be a focal point of the film this
like any story worth telling is all
about a girl that girl the girl next
door Mary Jane Watson the woman I've
loved since before I even liked girls
many times we see the pair interact both
as Peter or spider-man and MJ Mary Jane
becomes fascinated with spider-man when
he saves her life from the Green Goblin
little did she know that this was going
to become a pattern one night MJ is
cornered by some men in an alley
spider-man comes to her rescue he
quickly flees though because his mask
was not on throughout the fight but she
pursues him spider-man appears upside
down and Mary Jane says she wants to
thank him for saving her life again she
pulls down the mask just enough to kiss
him and possibly one of the most iconic
kissing scenes on-screen was born what
made it great was the unique twist it
put on the kiss we'd seen kisses in the
rain and kisses given after damsels in
distress' had been rescued but never
something like this it has been parodied
and imitated too many times to count
ask anyone about the spider-man kiss and
they will know exactly what you were
talking about we want to hear what you
guys think what's your favorite onscreen
kiss what do you want to see us cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
us know to keep in touch you can find me
on Facebook Twitter or Instagram and you
can find me on Twitter Instagram or
Twitter I stream on Wednesday nights I
was having this strangest dream Heather
you were telling me a story oh no that
wasn't a dream that really happened yeah
we wanted to do like a whole Princess
Bride bit with you since you were sick
okay but then there's this weird part
where Heather was talking about IATA her
forbidden love with that stupid dummy
I'm so creepy I am just a steer too
confused about this as you are
happy Valentine's Day
[Music]
[Applause]
you